first off let's start on a happy note we
just celebrated 18 years with Melissa
what is the secret like help us lost
souls out here thank you love attention
compliments I love you you're the best
you're the a lot of hanky-panky gotta
keep that going see a lot of married
couples they forget that yeah they
forget you know you have kids oh my God
we have no time you're called in your
busy schedule the kids are no you always
got to fit them always date for the rest
of your lives and you'll be good well
it's worked it's where it doesn't matter
what is going to surprise Jersey fans
the most
there's an enormous amount of drama
and drama fun is exciting it's exciting
it's sad it's fun it's drama you know
it's it's Jersey Housewives for the past
13 years right so obviously you've been
asked about this 100 times but not being
at the wedding yeah what was the most
challenging part I guess about seeing it
on social media just seeing it
everywhere how does that make you feel I
was it was it was very hard it was sad
you know and I would love to be there as
my sister I'm going to be honest I'm a
band I'm not gonna sit here hey honey I
don't care no other me to the fullest
and um it's I'm not happy about it I
don't want this in my time
thank you how are you speaking of
someone who's excited Family actually
had a very similar situation
you want to be yeah
thank you